local lockdowns are still a very new
tactic but will they work
there's been huge disparities between
infection rates across
england the worst affected local
authorities over here leicester
and ashford have seen over a thousand
people infected per
100 000 of the population while the
areas faring best actually all in the
southwest
have had rates as low as 78 per 100 000
you can see that disparity more clearly
when you look at this map the darker
colors here
show the areas with the highest
infection rates as you can see it's the
southwest they've really done the best
throughout this crisis
uh whole sways of the south and the east
also not too bad
when it comes to the areas with the
highest infection rates
there's the odd one that sits on its own
leicester for example there in the dark
blue
but most of them have been clustered
together up there in the north
and the northwest taking a closer look
at that region one of the worst affected
areas has been blackburn with darwin
with 763 cases per 100 000
it was singled out as an area of concern
but it hasn't been locked down
in neighboring lancashire those local
disparities are really
on show the two local authorities here
preston and rebel valley share a border
but as you can see they have extremely
different infection rates
if you're saying to me something has to
give and local lockdowns
are the best tool we have up our sleeve
for achieving that
i kind of understand that as long as
it's done
with conviction and with the tools in
place to really be able to
nail things down properly in real time
the reality is we're just not sure yet
whether local lockdowns work
leicester is the only case study we have
this shows the infection rate in that
city over the last
six weeks the lighter bar in the middle
there shows the date that lockdown
was imposed we've got the three weeks
before that the two weeks after
and this bar here is the most recent
data we have from yesterday
now it's the speed at which cases rise
which is concerning when it comes to
this virus
so that big weekly jump there just
before lockdown was of major concern
but since then the speed at which
infections have risen has leveled off as
you can see those bars there
much less steep so that shows lockdown
has definitely had an impact
however large numbers of people in
leicester are still
affected the prime minister said that
improved more
localized data means that restrictions
in leicester can now be eased
local leaders wanted to see it much
sooner residents
have been contacting me and my
colleagues on leicester city council
asking for information
about why uh why their area their
community
is being treated in the way that it is
and we weren't able to answer those
questions and what we'd have now is that
more granular data that we've been
asking for
now it's important to exercise caution
with these local figures remember
an outbreak in a factory for example can
substantially impact local infection
rates
but they nevertheless show there are
complicated decisions ahead
for leaders both local and national